dude it's great to see you where are you
i'm in
malta the beautiful island country of
malta which is about
i don't know 100 miles maybe not even 50
miles south of sicily um so we're in the
middle of the mediterranean and i'm on
my last
leg
of a
very long
and exhausting shoot so it's so nice to
see you this is like you're the glimmer
of light at the end of the tunnel for me
like i'm coming home
yes yes well we all miss you uh what are
you shooting
um uh it's a film called the last voyage
of the demeter and it's um
interesting story it is uh lifted from a
chapter from brom stoker's dracula and
it's actually a story that because i
write as well and it's a story i've
always wanted to write into a
a screenplay it's a fascinating tale it
reminds me of um kind of like alien
except set on a schooner in 1897 so it's
the boat that
travels from
bulgaria to london and the crew doesn't
realize that in the hold is the prince
of darkness himself dracula and all of
his belongings because he's moving
himself to carthage carfax abbey and
london so the whole film takes place on
this ship uh from beginning to end and
um wow we've been living we've been
living the life of it feels like i've
been at sea for four and a half months
man how often how many crew members got
sick
oh you know what um we did a sailing
thing but most of the time we're on a
control there are um we're we're in
this giant tank
on the edge of the sea
so and it's like an infinity pool like
optical illusion so i don't know because
if someone got sick they weren't stuck
with us they could just hop off and get
get get away but i i saw at least
four or five people and we're on um what
do you call them you know the things
that make something shake what is that
always like
you know doing this number and right
effects machines or whatever that just
kind of turned the boat and things like
that
wow and you and you wrote this
no i i didn't sorry i didn't i
i always wanted to always wanted
um
about two years ago i pitched the idea
um to
a friend who's an exec who said there's
already a script and it's amazing and
it's being made by amblin
and then i just did everything i could
to get an audition for the film which i
did and miraculously i got cast so are
you serious what are the odds of that
you want to do something you find out
there's a script you get an audition and
you get the part
i went i hadn't gone this hard and heavy
after something in
i feel like since maybe like theater day
like i
chased this thing fought for this thing
i put together the best t because this
is covid times you know i had to tape
this audition with
my lovely understanding and patient wife
who helped me as three massive setups
for the audition big dialect work it's a
period piece
it's a character that's very much
not like anything i've had the privilege
of doing before he he moves differently
than i've ever moved he speaks
differently than i've ever spoken and so
it was like i i almost built a whole
character just for the i mean i did i
thought i built a whole role for just
the audition
and when when i sent it off
i
honestly had a lot of peace
because i said there's
just no way there's just no way and then
lo and behold like a few weeks later